this morning students returned to
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School for
a second day of modified classes about
95 percent were back on campus yesterday
two weeks after that horrible deadly
shooting they were accompanied by more
than 200 police officers about 150 grief
counselors and 40 therapy dogs Adriana
Diaz is in parkland Florida with what
the students faced Adriana good morning
good morning the school day started
yesterday with the Pledge of Allegiance
that a 17 second moment of silence
honoring the victims one student told us
that the principal went over the PA
system and said we are Eagle strong
today we reclaimed the nest Stoneman
Douglas students walked out of the red
gates just before noon Wednesday marking
the end of a difficult first day back
hours earlier 15 year old freshman
Isabella van der Lac a lot of shoe
person we should leave earlier and her
parents prepared for the emotional day
ahead and made the five minute drive to
school when do you think things will go
back to normal for you
[Music]
the armed police officers reminded
Isabella of that day two weeks ago while
some students gave officers high-fives
others felt uneasy by the tightened
security everywhere you look is a police
officer or like a service dog and it's
just uncomfortable to help comfort
students 150 counselors and more than 40
therapy dogs were on hand
we followed Isabella's mother as she
picked her up from school it was good we
laughed again her classmate Martin Duke
died in the shooting the teacher moved
around the desks but still seeing his
empty desk really really hurt I'm
emotional every second of the day
Andrew Pollock who lost his daughter
meadow was also at the school Wednesday
he says the students returned offered
relief she knew how to get what she
wanted she was a very powerful strong
woman no one should go through this what
I got to go through but that's what
empowers me to try and fix this we need
to make it so when the kid goes to
school they're safe there are men on a
mission that's what happens they when
they murder your kid there's nothing
that could stop me right now the
superintendent said that 15 students and
for teachers have asked about
transferring the school returns to a
full day scheduled next week teachers
told us they're not worried about
academics they're letting students talk
and play games to help them heal Gayle
all right Adriana thank you very much